you smoke weed with Willie Nelson right
yeah I'm not very good at smoking weed
me neither it hits me all wrong what did
he say to you he said hey uh Johnny come
on over here and smoke some weed with me
no no he doesn't ask he just sits down
and Joints start going around and uh how
many hits did you take on that job oh I
only took two and that was enough oh
yeah yeah imagine if you did like 10. I
would be that would pass out you'd be
dead yeah there's uh there's been a few
times people just smoking Jason under
sakar who was in our movie who's great
in the last bit with Aaron McGee
prank but he was doing a documentary on
Willie and their cameraman were filming
on his bus and the joints were going
around the cameraman took a hit and uh a
few hits and all of a sudden the camera
guy goes face first in the floor of the
camera why do you think the pot's so
strong now what do they do they treated
or they just know how to grow it better
I'm not have you I haven't I'm not
believable